l'état français condamné par la justice
c'est dans le cadre de la sphère du
siècle sur la crise climatique que
l'état a été déclarée en partie
responsable la justice a tranché en
faveur des les organisations de défense
de l'environnement qui pointait du doigt
l'inaction de l'état le tribunal
administratif qui ordonne au
gouvernement de je cite prendre toutes
les mesures utiles de nature à réparer
le préjudice écologique et prévenir
l'aggravation des dommages écoutez
l'analyse de marina qu'elle met
présidente de l'association wald légal
c'est un signal fort puisqu'il s'agit
donc pour la deuxième fois d'une
décision de justice qui vient confirmer
que l'état a bien l'obligation de
respecter les engagements de l'accord de
paris en revanche ce qui est un peu
décevant c'est que le juge considère
donc que il est anne la responsabilité
de compenser que 15 millions de tonnes
équivalent co2 au lieu des 62 millions
de tonnes équivalent co2 qu'il avait
constaté comme étant manquant sur le
budget précédent et malheureusement donc
il ya quelque chose qui manque parce
qu'en fait on ne peut pas juste
compenser des émissions carbone le
retard que nous prenons dans la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique elle
n'a pas que des déguise impact en
matière d'émissions de co2 c'est aussi
une destruction de la biodiversité une
érosion des sols une disparition des
ressources en eau et ça malheureusement
ce n'est pas dit dans cette décision de
justice